If you're lucky, summer gives you time to breathe. Maybe go on vacation, slow down. You finally have a chance to get to that long list of things you've been putting off. Books to read, exercise, spending some time on yourself. The episode you're about to hear is part of our summer series about rebooting and reimagining our lives. We're calling it U2.0. This week we bring your conversation from the fall of 2016. It explores the idea that the chaos of your regular life
如果幸运的话，夏天会给你喘息的机会。也许去度假，放慢脚步。你终于有机会处理那些一直拖延的待办事项了。比如读书、锻炼，或者花点时间关注自己。你即将听到的这一集是我们关于重启和重塑生活系列节目的一部分。我们称之为“U2.0”。本周，我们将带你回顾2016年秋天的一次对话。它探讨了一个观点，即你日常生活的混乱
might have some secret benefits. If you're a parent, you've probably told your kids a thousand times, your room is a mess clean it up. We hear the same message in other contexts, managers at companies around the world tell their employees to get organized. Here in the United States, we elect presidents to go clean up Washington. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. My guest today has a radical idea. In many cases, he says,
可能隐藏着一些秘密的好处。如果你是父母，你可能已经对孩子说过一千遍：“你的房间太乱了，收拾一下。”我们在其他语境中也听到过同样的信息，世界各地的公司经理告诉员工要保持条理。在美国，我们选举总统去清理华盛顿的乱象。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我今天的嘉宾有一个激进的观点。他说，在许多情况下，
it's disorder rather than order, that's our friend. Tim Hartford is the author of Messy, the power of disorder to transform our lives. He joined us recently for a live taping, just blocks from the White House, at NPR's Weekend in Washington. It's an annual event that brings together public radio fans and supporters.
混乱而非秩序，才是我们的朋友。蒂姆·哈福德是《混乱：无序的力量如何改变我们的生活》一书的作者。他最近参加了我们在华盛顿NPR周末活动现场的录制，地点就在白宫附近。这是一个汇集了公共广播粉丝和支持者的年度活动。
Tim Hartford, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you very much, Shankar. I want to begin by playing you a piece of music come about? What's the story? It's beautiful, isn't it? Two of my children were born to that. It was played by Keith Jarrett, great jazz pianist in 1975 in Cologne, and if you had been there two or three hours before the concert, you would not have expected things to go well. Keith Jarrett had just Mae'n gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch yw'n gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r
蒂姆·哈福德，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢，尚卡尔。我想先为你播放一段音乐。它是怎么来的？背后的故事是什么？它很美，不是吗？我的两个孩子出生时就听着这段音乐。这是伟大的爵士钢琴家基思·贾瑞特于1975年在科隆演奏的。如果你在音乐会开始前两三个小时到场，你绝不会想到事情会进展顺利。基思·贾瑞特当时刚刚
gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r recorded the concert because they want a documentary evidence of what a musical catastrophe sounds like So they could play it to future promoters to tell them to do a good job and get a proper piano But in fact, it's a masterpiece It's Keith Jarrett's most popular work. In fact, it's the best-selling jazz album in history solo jazz album in history and the best-selling piano album in history is the Column Concert. And the surprising thing is that all the adjustments that Jarrett had
录制了这场音乐会，因为他们想留下音乐灾难的证据，好让未来的推广人听听，告诉他们要做好工作，找一架像样的钢琴。但事实上，这是一部杰作。它是基思·贾瑞特最受欢迎的作品。事实上，它是历史上最畅销的爵士专辑，也是历史上最畅销的钢琴专辑，这就是《科隆音乐会》。令人惊讶的是，贾瑞特为了应对这架糟糕的钢琴所做的所有调整，反而让音乐变得更好了。
to make to cope with this bad piano made the music better. So we avoided the harsh upper registers, he stuck to the middle of the keyboard, that makes it sound very soothing. But he also had to compensate for the fact that piano was so quiet, so he had these rolling repetitive riffs in the bass to try to get some resonance. And he also just stood up and pounded down on the keys. So you can hear him moaning in frustration during the concert. He's hating it, but it is amazing. And that combination of the peacefulness and the dynamism makes this electrifying piece of music.
所以他避开了刺耳的高音区，坚持在键盘的中音区演奏，这让声音听起来非常舒缓。但他还必须弥补钢琴声音太小的问题，所以他在低音区加入了循环重复的即兴演奏，试图获得一些共鸣。他还站起来用力敲击琴键。所以你可以在音乐会中听到他因沮丧而发出的呻吟声。他讨厌那架钢琴，但效果却令人惊叹。这种宁静与活力的结合，造就了这段激动人心的音乐。
So he did not expect that a bad piano would produce a great concert, but in fact it did. And the argument of my book is very often we're faced with the unplayable piano and actually we produce something great out of it. You have a number of examples besides Keet Gerrit about how disruptions and inconveniences and surprises can sometimes have paradoxically good effects on us, even though we all try to avoid those disruptions. You talk about commuters, for example, who suddenly have to find a new way to work, or scientists who are working on so many projects that they are discombobulated because they don't know what they're working on.
所以他没想到一架糟糕的钢琴会产生一场伟大的音乐会，但事实确实如此。我这本书的论点是，我们经常面临“无法弹奏的钢琴”，但实际上我们却从中创造出了伟大的东西。除了基思·贾瑞特，你还有很多例子说明干扰、不便和意外有时会产生反直觉的好效果，尽管我们都试图避免这些干扰。例如，你谈到了那些突然不得不寻找新上班路线的通勤者，或者那些因为手头项目太多而感到困惑、不知道自己在做什么的科学家。
In many of these cases, you find that disorder and confusion could actually be helpful. Yeah, so in the case of commuters, there was a transport strike in London a couple of years ago. Shut down, not all, but most of the London underground stations a'r transport strike yn lwmg i'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gydol, mae'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n g ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn y years ago. One of the things I want to do in this conversation is try and tease apart when messiness can be our friend and when it can be our enemy. There's a reason many of us try and avoid messiness. It's because messiness causes delays, it causes disruptions, you're ending up, you end up being late for some things. And I'm wondering as I read some of the examples in your book, whether
在许多这类案例中，你发现混乱和困惑实际上可能是有益的。是的，以通勤者为例，几年前伦敦发生了一次交通罢工。关闭了伦敦地铁的部分（而非全部）车站。在这次对话中，我想做的一件事是试着理清混乱何时能成为我们的朋友，何时又会成为我们的敌人。我们许多人试图避免混乱是有原因的。因为混乱会导致延误，导致中断，最终导致你迟到。在阅读你书中的一些例子时，我很好奇，是否
it was the case that messiness helps people who actually have a base of preparation. So in other words, Keith Jarrett, he's a professional musician, he's very gifted, he's practiced and he's learned the rules of how to play a proper piano for years and years and years. You place me before that piano, and what you're going to hear is not genius, what you're going to hear is just a mess. And the reason Keith Jarrett could adapt was because he had the base of knowing the rules to now say I can throw out the rule book and create something brilliant.
混乱确实能帮助那些有准备基础的人？换句话说，基思·贾瑞特是一位专业音乐家，他非常有天赋，经过多年练习，掌握了演奏正规钢琴的规则。如果你把我放在那架钢琴前，你听到的不会是天才之作，而是一团糟。基思·贾瑞特之所以能适应，是因为他有深厚的基础，知道规则，所以现在他可以说：“我可以抛开规则手册，创造出一些辉煌的东西。”
Yeah, I think that's absolutely right, Chan-Kar. Is it okay, can I open a big bag of complexity science on you? Absolutely. Okay, so basically, if you are trying to solve a very complex problem, we have various algorithms that try to solve this. And we'll come to the question of skill in a second. a'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r ymdwysio'r gwybod, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymwyr, gwybod ymdwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch ysgwch y ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymw yn ymwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn So for all the children who are listening to this podcast, I want to make clear that you're not saying that every time your parent tells you to clean up the room, you should just say, Tim Hartford says, I shouldn't. Well, I have to say, since writing the book, I have stopped asking my children to clear up their room. And the reason is, the reason is, I read an amazing study that had been conducted by two British psychologists, Mae'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaith a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny hyn, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny, a fwy hynny hynny, a fwybod. Mae'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r gwybod i'r pryddu cymryddiad o'r pryddu cymryddiad. Mae'n ffwrdd o'r pryddu cymryddiad,
是的，我认为你说得完全正确，尚卡尔。可以吗？我可以向你抛出一个关于复杂性科学的大话题吗？当然。好的，基本上，如果你试图解决一个非常复杂的问题，我们有各种算法来尝试解决它。我们稍后再谈技能的问题。对于所有正在收听这个播客的孩子们，我想明确一点：我并不是说每次父母让你收拾房间时，你都应该说：“蒂姆·哈福德说我不应该收拾。”好吧，我必须说，自从写了这本书，我就不再要求我的孩子们收拾房间了。原因在于，我读到了一项由两位英国心理学家进行的研究，
ac mae'r pryddu cymryddiad o'r pryddu cymryddiad, ac mae'r pryddu cymryddiad, ac mae'r pryddu cymryddiad, ac mae'r pryddu cymryddiad, ac mae'r pryddu cymryddiad, ac mae'r pryddu cymryddiad, ac mae'r pryddu cymryddiad, ac mae'r pryddu cymryddiad,
这项研究表明，混乱的环境可能有助于激发创造力。这听起来可能很疯狂，但研究发现，在混乱环境中工作的人，比在整洁环境中工作的人更有创意。他们更愿意尝试新事物，更愿意打破常规。所以，如果你想让你的孩子更有创造力，也许你应该让他们保持房间的混乱。
ac mae'r pryddu cymryddiad, ac mae'r pryddu cymryddiad, ac mae'r pryddu cymryddiad, ac mae'r pryddu cymryddiad, ac mae'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweith I'm ever a boss, nobody should make me a boss, by the way. If I'm ever a boss, I will never impose a clean desk policy. And number two, me and my wife, we kind of are the boss in our house. And I no longer ask my children to tidy their rooms. And you know what? We don't argue about it as much. And the rooms are kind of as messy as they ever were.
如果我当了老板，顺便说一句，没人应该让我当老板。如果我当了老板，我绝不会强行推行“桌面整洁政策”。第二，我和我妻子在家里算是“老板”。我不再要求孩子们整理房间。你知道吗？我们在这件事上争吵得少了。房间依然像以前一样乱。
It hasn't made any difference to the physical state of the rooms. It's just a little bit more peace. All right, so that's a perfect segue to what I want to talk about next, because I actually want to talk about office space and how we organize office spaces. And in fact, I have a clip from the cult classic movie office space, which I'm going to play for you. Hi, Milton. What's happening?
这并没有改变房间的物理状态。只是多了一点安宁。好的，这完美地引出了我接下来想谈的话题，因为我实际上想谈谈办公空间以及我们如何组织办公空间。事实上，我有一个关于邪典电影《办公空间》的片段，我想放给你听。嗨，米尔顿。怎么了？
I'm going to have to ask you to go ahead and move your desk again. So, if you could go ahead and get it as far back against that wall as possible, that would be great. No, no, because that way we'll have some room for some of these boxes and things we need to put in here. No room. And, oh, there it is. What? Here, let me just go ahead and get that front.
我得请你再挪一下你的办公桌。所以，如果你能把它尽可能往后靠在那面墙上，那就太好了。不行，不行，因为那样我们就有空间放一些我们需要放在这里的箱子和东西了。没空间了。哦，就在那儿。什么？来，让我把前面那个拿走。
Great. So if you could just get to that as soon as possible, that would be terrific. Okay. Thanks a bunch, Milton. Bye. Okay. I can sit and building on fire.
太好了。所以如果你能尽快处理好，那就太棒了。好的。非常感谢，米尔顿。再见。好吧。我可以坐在着火的楼里。
I take a tim that you are not a fan of fascist office managers. You do also tell the story in the book about Steve Jobs at Pixar and some of the ideas he had about how to organize office space to make people more collaborative and some of the ways that might have backed by. Yeah, the Pixar story I think is fascinating. So Steve Jobs, majority shareholder at Pixar, had a big hand in designing the Pixar building. And one of his big ideas is we are going to make all the bathrooms in this building in the middle of the building. We're just going to have two big restrooms, a pair of restrooms in the heart of the building. ymdwch i'n gweithio'r gweithio, mae'n gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r
蒂姆，看得出来你不是法西斯式办公室经理的粉丝。你在书中还讲述了史蒂夫·乔布斯在皮克斯的故事，以及他关于如何组织办公空间以促进员工协作的一些想法，以及这些想法可能适得其反的方式。是的，皮克斯的故事我认为非常迷人。史蒂夫·乔布斯作为皮克斯的大股东，在设计皮克斯大楼时发挥了很大作用。他的一大想法是：我们要把大楼里所有的洗手间都设在大楼中央。我们要在楼中心只设两个大洗手间，一对洗手间。
gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r
这在纸面上听起来是个好主意，乔布斯先生，但我每小时需要去三次洗手间。而你刚刚把洗手间设在离我办公桌十分钟路程的地方，算算账，这行不通。史蒂夫·乔布斯做了一件了不起的事。他退让了。他说：“好吧，我错了。我会找到另一种方式来创造偶然的互动。”
gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'ael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o'r gael o I know this sounds like a great idea on paper, Mr Jobs, but I need to go to the restroom three times an hour. And you've just made the restroom ten minutes away from my desk, do the maths, and it's not going to work. And Steve Jobs did an amazing thing. He backed down. He said, OK, I'm wrong. I will find another way to create serendipitous interactions, and you can, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy, aegy,bod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwybod, yn gwy people feel they have control over. It looks like a total mess. In other words, it looks like your children's rooms.
人们觉得他们能掌控这些空间。它看起来一团糟。换句话说，它看起来就像你孩子们的房间。
Yeah, maybe slightly more creative than my children's rooms, but my children aspire towards the whole Disney castle thing. Tim Halford comes from Britain. We're having this chat in the United States. In both countries, there have been enormous political upheavals recently. When we come back, I'm going to ask Tim about messiness in public life and in democracy.
是的，可能比我孩子们的房间稍微有创意一点，但我孩子们追求的是那种迪士尼城堡风格。蒂姆·哈福德来自英国。我们现在是在美国进行这次谈话。在两国，最近都发生了巨大的政治动荡。回来后，我要问问蒂姆关于公共生活和民主中的混乱问题。
Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. With Brexit and the election of Donald Trump Tim, we've had populous revolutions on both sides of the Atlantic that reject the advice of scientists and economists, experts in general. Democracy, of course, is famously messy. Could you remind people why it's such a good thing? Mae'n gweithio'r ysgwch yn y fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwylwyr i'n fwy How is this going to make me stronger? How is this going to make my society stronger? What are the solutions that are going to come out of disappointment? Donald Trump ran a campaign that many people thought was extremely disordered.
请继续收听。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。随着英国脱欧和唐纳德·特朗普的当选，蒂姆，我们在大西洋两岸都经历了民粹主义革命，拒绝了科学家、经济学家和一般专家的建议。当然，民主以混乱著称。你能提醒大家为什么这其实是一件好事吗？这怎么能让我变得更强大？这怎么能让我的社会变得更强大？从失望中会产生什么样的解决方案？唐纳德·特朗普发起了一场许多人认为极其混乱的竞选活动。
He didn't listen to the experts. He went off script all the time. He said things that people said would be sure to make him lose. Now, your book came out only a few weeks ago, but clearly, he must have read an early draft. yw'n gweithio'r gweithio yn gweithio. Mae'r gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweithio yn gweith ymwch i'n gweithio yn gweithio. Iw'n gweithio yn ymwch i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio. I'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i'n gweithio i o'r ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddod yn ddododd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddodd yn ddoddodd yn ddod i'n gweithio'r yw'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio'r ysgwyrddio' and Noble are more confused than we are. And as long as Bonson Noble are more confused than we are, we're doing okay. He was very, very clear about this and it has proved very effective. I want to talk about another example of messiness in public life. And I want you to watch this video which describes a very famous speech.
他不听专家的建议。他总是脱稿演讲。他说了一些人们认为肯定会让他失败的话。现在，你的书才出版几周，但显然，他一定读过初稿。只要邦诺书店（Barnes & Noble）比我们更困惑，我们就没问题。他对此非常非常明确，而且事实证明非常有效。我想谈谈公共生活中混乱的另一个例子。我想让你看这段视频，它描述了一场非常著名的演讲。
And I want to ask the question right after it. We can never be satisfied as long as our children are stripped of their selfhood and robbed of their dignity by sign stating for whites own name. We cannot be satisfied as long as a Negro in Mississippi cannot go, and a Negro in New York believes he has nothing for which to go. Yeah. So as you can see from that speech, Tim, Martin Luther King is reading from a script.
我想在视频之后问一个问题。只要我们的孩子被剥夺了自我，被写着“仅限白人”的标语剥夺了尊严，我们就永远不会满足。只要密西西比州的黑人不能去投票，而纽约的黑人认为他没有什么可投的，我们就不能满足。是的。正如你从那场演讲中看到的，蒂姆，马丁·路德·金当时正在照着稿子读。
And he has some nice line there, but it's a writerly line. But at a certain point in this speech, he decides to leave the script behind and turn his eyes to the audience and here's what we see after that. I still have a dream. It is a dream deeply rooted in the American dream. I have a dream that one day this nation will rise up, live out the true meaning of its creed. We hold these
他那里有一些不错的台词，但那是写出来的台词。但在演讲的某个时刻，他决定放下稿子，转而注视观众，这就是之后我们看到的情景。我仍然有一个梦想。这个梦想深深扎根于美国梦之中。我梦想有一天，这个国家会站起来，实现其信条的真正含义。我们认为这些
truths to be self-evident that all men are created. Talk about this for a second, because you talk about this speech in the book and you talk about this moment when King left his notes behind and essentially stepped off the ledge of what he knew and what he was certain about and just rode the wave of what the crowd was telling him and what he was feeling. He had prepared that speech meticulously the night before and it's then at very late. He was operating on a number of constraints. It was quite a tight time schedule. The eyes of the world were on him, he knew that. There were also various political a'r
真理是不言而喻的，即人人生而平等。谈谈这个吧，因为你在书中谈到了这场演讲，也谈到了金放下笔记、本质上从他所知和确定的边缘走出来，只是顺应人群告诉他的东西和他所感受到的东西的那一刻。他前一天晚上精心准备了那场演讲，而且是在很晚的时候。他在多种限制下工作。时间非常紧迫。全世界的目光都注视着他，他知道这一点。还有各种政治
gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r
现在让我们回到我们的社区，作为“创造性不满协会”的成员。他没有这么说。相反，他说：“回到阿拉巴马州。”
gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r Now let us go back to our communities as members for the Society for Creative Disatisfaction. He doesn't say it. He says instead, go back to Alabama.
回到阿拉巴马州，回到南卡罗来纳州，回到佐治亚州，回到路易斯安那州，回到我们北部城市的贫民窟和贫民区。又是一阵停顿，台下的人知道他已经脱稿了。伟大的福音歌手玛哈莉亚·杰克逊对他大喊，因为她曾在教堂听他谈论过这个梦想。她大喊：“马丁，告诉他们那个梦想。”
Go back to Alabama, go back to South Carolina, go back to Georgia, go back to Louisiana, go back to the slums and get holes in our northern cities. And there's another pause, and the people behind him on the stage know he's not on the script anymore. And Mahalia Jackson, great gospel singer, yells out to him because she's heard him talking in church about this dream. She yells out, tell him about the dream Martin.
然后他开始即兴发挥。就在那时，他打动了人群。我想最后问你几个私人问题。我了解到，写完这本书后，每当你发现自己陷入混乱并向妻子寻求安慰时，她现在会提醒你，陷入混乱是一件好事。是的。
And then he starts to improvise. And that is when he touches the crowd. I want to wrap by asking you a few personal questions. I understand that after writing this book, every time you find yourself in a mess and you turn to your wife for comfort, she now reminds you that being in a mess is a good thing. Yeah.
是的。
Actually, just two days ago, Shankar, I was trying to check into a hotel, a Dublin airport. Ym gydwch, ac mae'n gydwch yn ffordd o'r ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o fforddd o ffordd o fforddd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o ffordd o that I would be able to get. And when I showed up at the airport hotel, they didn't have my reservation. And they were full. So no, we're just leaving. And as I toured Dublin in a taxi looking for hotels that were open, I could just hear my wife's voice in my head saying, this is making you smarter Tim. This is what you say.
事实上，就在两天前，Shankar，我试图在都柏林机场的一家酒店办理入住。我以为我能订到房间。但当我到达机场酒店时，他们没有我的预订记录，而且已经客满了。所以不，我们只能离开。当我在都柏林坐着出租车寻找还有空房的酒店时，我脑海里一直回响着我妻子的声音，她说：这会让你变得更聪明，Tim。这就是你常说的话。
This is making you more creative. So I've really sort of created a rod to beat myself with. But I think it's important. Mae'n gwaithio'r rhodd i'n gwaithio yn gwaithio yn gwaithio. Mae'n gwaithio yn gwaithio yn gwaithio yn gwaithio yn gwaithio. Mae'n gwaithio yn gwaithio yn gwaithio yn gwaithio yn gwaithio. Mae'n gwaithio yn gwaithio yn gwaithio yn gwaithio yn gwaithio. Mae'n gwaithio yn gwaithio yn gwaithio yn gwaithio. Mae'n gwaithio yn gwaithio yn gwaithio.
这会让你变得更有创造力。所以我真的是给自己挖了个坑。但我认为这很重要。
Mae'n gwaithio yn gwaithio yn gwaithio. Mae'n gwaithio yn gwaithio. Mae'n gwaithio yn gwaithio. Mae'n gwaithio yn gwaithio. Mae'n gwaithio yn gwaithio. Mae'n gwaith ymwch, yn ymwch, yn ymwch, yn ymwch, yn y, a'r hynny, a'r hynny, a'r hynweithio'r oes yn y problem, mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem,
这在解决问题时很有用。
mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, Mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, Mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, mae'n gweithio'r oes yn y problem, Thank you for joining me today. Thanks, Shrek. APPLAUSE Hidden Brain is produced by Maggie Penman, Jennifer Schmidt, Raina Cohen, Lucy Perkins, Parth Shah, and Renee Clar. Our supervising producer is Tara Boyle.
这在解决问题时很有用。感谢您今天加入我。谢谢，Shrek。掌声。Hidden Brain 由 Maggie Penman、Jennifer Schmidt、Raina Cohen、Lucy Perkins、Parth Shah 和 Renee Clar 制作。我们的监制是 Tara Boyle。
Our unsung hero this week is an institution. We want to thank the NPR Foundation Board of Trustees, many of whom joined us for this taping with Tim Harford. They played a vital role in getting hidden brain off the ground, not just financial support, but guidance and emotional support as well. I'm so grateful. Next week we'll continue our U2.0 series with an episode about how to achieve your dreams.
我们本周的无名英雄是一个机构。我们要感谢 NPR 基金会董事会，他们中的许多人参加了我们与 Tim Harford 的这次录制。他们在 Hidden Brain 的起步阶段发挥了至关重要的作用，不仅提供了财政支持，还提供了指导和情感支持。我非常感激。下周我们将继续我们的 U2.0 系列节目，探讨如何实现梦想。
Really. I'm Shankar Vidantam, and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
真的。我是 Shankar Vedantam，这是 NPR。目前本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。